♪ [music] ♪
- [male] We are the paradoxical ape,
bi-pedal, naked, large brain, long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shake the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Mark] Before I start you'll notice that
there are actually two speakers here. I'm
going to speak out of both sides of my
mouth. The other speaker listed here is
Carol Padden who was summoned to
Sacramento in her deaconal duties. And so,
Carol asked me to present the work. Carol
and I have known each other since she was
a toddler and we've been doing this. This
particular work is joint work of a large
number of people spread around the world
and I happen to be the other member of
this group present here and so I've been
given this honor. Here are some of the
other places. There's UCSD here of course,
Tufts University in Boston, and the
University of Haifa in Israel. If you look
very carefully, you can see me. Let me
see. In any case, you can see a head
behind the van. My job for the last 15
years has been to drive the van because
that's a man's job and that's what I do.
Okay. I'll talk very briefly about sign
languages of the world. First really most
important thing is that there is no single
universal sign language. There are many
sign languages and we've actually learned
a little bit about Nicaraguan sign
language. Sign languages in general are
young languages. They're usually small
languages. There are some very large ones
like American sign language, but American
sign language or Japanese sign language,
those are actually atypical in terms of
their size. What are these languages used
for? Well, they're used for social
communication like any other language.
Most sign languages are actually quite
young. The ones we're going to be talking
about are very new and were actually
created spontaneously in much the same way
as Nicaraguan sign language.
Others, the oldest sign language for which
we have actual records is French sign
language from which American sign language
comes. But we actually have records from
classical Greek times indicating that
people were signing back the. And there is
a wonderful picture that I don't have here
of a Greek vase that seems to indicate
people signing thousands of years ago.
Most sign languages are fairly small
languages and those are the ones that
we're going to be kind of concentrating on
here. We're also interested in new sign
languages, sign languages that are
emerging, and this is very much within the
spirit of what we're talking about here.
You can actually watch languages evolve.
You can't watch language as a human
ability evolve, but individual languages
you can actually watch. Now, these new
sign languages they're created under a
variety of conditions, villages, schools,
wherever deaf people can find each other,
they will pretty much create a sign
language. And the patterns that how these
sign languages are transmitted, vary quite
widely among each other. But what really
matters is that sign languages usually
start off as being iconic. So we're very
much within some of the stuff that Kenny
showed you, where you start off with some
sort of iconic patterns. Eventually they
become less iconic and this is something I
could show you examples of later. It's
really quite wonderful. But they are all
built on the resources of the body, so
people have a body and they use this
physical body in order to communicate
visually with one another.
All right. Sign languages of the world,
there are many and there are many
different types. Home sign, this is the
language of the individual who grows up in
a household where everyone else is
hearing. There are family sign languages.
A case that's just emerged recently is
something that's called natural sign
language. It's just a sign language that
has grown up in Nepal, among a community
of people. It's called natural because it
grew up by itself, not under any kind of
forced circumstances. Village sign
languages, that's a very recent, I'd say
the last 20 years or so people have begun
interested in that and our work basically
is we work with village sign languages.
And then of course, the Nicaraguan sign
language which grew up in a near urban
environment but which is also very new.
The point is there are these many, many
different kinds of sign languages.
So our question is, well, how did they get
that way? We know what they're for and we
know quite vividly as we've seen examples
alread, these people can communicate quite
well. But how did they get there? And how
did they get there so quickly? Even the
youngest sign languages have grammatical
categories. They have fairly well defined
word orders. They have modifiers, these
kind of trappings of fully evolved sign
languages. So how did they get there?
Well, the way they get there is basically
as we said by using the body and
originally by using the body in iconic
ways.
Now I'm going to talking to you about a
very, very small type of organization, but
I think it is emblematic of how sign
languages can use iconic patterns to
organize themselves. Okay. So we have to
make a distinction between two different
types of iconicity. I'll get to you in a
second how that works. So, what we're
going to do is we're kind of combining, I
think, two of the sorts of presentations
that you've seen here. We're going to be
looking at gesturers, non-signing hearing
gestures, and we're going to compare what
their gestures look like with the signs of
signers of new sign languages. In this
particular test, we're going to
concentrate on a fairly narrow task in
which we ask people, both hearing
gesturers and signers, to identify objects
in a picture task. So we show them a
picture and then we just ask them to
describe that picture.
For the hearing people we just say,
"Please gesture. Do not speak." And for
the signers we just ask them to sign the
thing for us. Okay, so that's the task. We
showed them pictures of tools and you'll
see why it's important. We vary the number
of tools so they don't worry about whether
the task, we kind of are distracting them
in a way. So they think we care about how
many but we don't really care about how
many. We just care about what it is. All
right. Now, very important point, we're
going to distinguish two types of
iconicity. The first we're calling here
imagistic iconicity and that is simply to
depict something.
But what we're really interested in is
patterned iconicity and this is again
within the spirit of what you've seen so
far today. The point is that when
languages emerge, patterns emerge, right?
So we're interested in the emergence of
patterns. We'll see here that this is a
very surprising pattern that's going to
emerge here and it's very small. It's not
a big pattern, just a small pattern. But I
hope you'll see that it's a pretty cool
pattern. Okay, all right. So, what we're
going to show you is we show a picture of
three paintbrushes and we asked UCSD
undergraduates to depict those in gesture.
You can see what they're depicting
is how the hand holds the object, that's
what they're doing, right? So these are
handling.
They're not very well dressed
but we'll have to ignore that. Your basic
UCSD undergraduates.
This guy is quite animated. All right. So
everybody sees what they do. Now what
we're going to do is we're going to show
you the same task except these are young
signers of Al-Sayyid Bedouin sign language
which we have talked about at previous
CARTA meetings.
This is a brand new sign language that was
created in an isolated Bedouin village by
a population initially of four siblings.
This is a village with a very high rate of
recessive deafness. Okay. And you're going
to see a big difference. What you're going
to see is that these people don't just
depict how you handle the object, but they
actually show what the shape of this tool
is, right? All of them. And by the way, we
haven't selected this. This is what they
do. People of different ages. Oh, let me
ask this question, did anybody notice the
word order difference between the two
populations? Right. So the UCSD
undergraduates do the number first and
then the thing and the Bedouin signers do
the thing first and then the number. So
they actually have a different word order
which I think is very cool. That's the
sort of thing that linguists think is
cool, right? Okay.
So we have these two terms. We have this
term handling to talk about what people
are doing and then we have this term
instrument to talk about showing the
actual thing. So what we're going to show
you is there's actually a difference
between the two groups. Basically, the
gesturers concentrate on simply the
handling, how you use it whereas the
signers will depict this as an instrument.
In other words, they show you how you use
it but they're most interested in how to
depict what the thing is. Okay. All right.
And we're looking at this in terms of a
pattern of iconicity that these things
share. Okay. All right. And you can see
this, actually not just across communities
but even within a community. So what we
have here is a hearing Bedouin gesturer
and he will tend to use the handling
whereas the deaf member of the same
community will also depict the object as
an instrument. Handling versus instrument.
Okay. Now, question is do we get
differences across groups? And that is of
course what happens. So here are hearing
Americans. They are overwhelmingly
handling, hearing Bedouins show almost the
same distribution. Here is the Bedouin
signers, right? The opposite. And guess
what, we get almost the same pattern for
American sign language. So hearing
gesturers concentrate on handling whereas
the deaf signers concentrate on the
instruments. And again we've given you the
same graph but in a slightly different
format to see how this works. Okay. Now
I'm going to show you another experiment
that actually I think gives you maybe a
slightly more subtle insight into how all
of this works. So what we do in this
experiment is we compare responses to
pictures with responses to video clips.
By the way, just a small autobiographical
point here, we used to use pictures all
the time when we first went into the
Bedouin village. We would just show people
pictures and the older Bedouin signers
really had no idea what to do. And we
thought that, "Well, it's just a picture.
Doesn't everybody know how to name a
picture? I mean, after all, you do that at
first grade." And then it suddenly
emerged. "Duh, first grade. These people
never got to first grade."
It turns out that picture naming is a
learned kind of task. There's nothing
natural about naming pictures. People
living out there in the wild don't have
pictures that they could point at. So this
was really a lesson, a cross-cultural
lesson, to us. We were interested in
whether simply showing people a static
picture versus showing people a video
would have an effect. And of course it
did, otherwise we wouldn't bother to show
it to you, right? Okay. So this is what we
showed people. So here is simply a brush
and here is a video clip of somebody using
the brush.
Everybody sees that? Okay. And we compare
people's responses to those and it is of
course actually what you might expect. So
when you show people a video, even
gesturers, they're much more likely to use
handling. But when you show gesturers a
picture then they are much more likely to
use instruments. Now a little bit of
tortured reasoning here, but the fact that
they were responding so overwhelmingly to
the handling response, the gesturers were
responding so overwhelmingly to the
handling response even with the pictures,
shows you that there is this major
difference between how the gesturers are
organizing their signal and how the
signers are organizing their symbol,
right.
So what we see is that there is this
difference, right? That it's been somehow
conventionalized and amplified in this one
sign language which is the Bedouin sign
language and even more so in the sign
language, in American sign language. I'm
not going to talk about it here, but it
turns out that when you look at other sign
languages, we looked at Israeli sign
language, it doesn't work that way. So I
think what's going on is that signers pick
up, they pick up on these patterns, this
is what we've seen before in earlier
presentations. They're picking up on these
patterns and what matters more is the
consistency of the abstract underlying
pattern.
This is a very abstract notion of handling
versus also depicting the instrument that
they are picking up on. And, by the way,
when you show people pieces of fruit, this
doesn't happen because of course pieces of
fruit are not instruments, at least
not usually. Okay. All right. I think the
one takeaway lesson that is really
important is that people have a drive to
communicate. We've talked about this. They
have a drive to share which Tecumseh Fitch
coined this wonderful German word which is
mitteilungsbedürfnis which. . . only in
German, right? But it basically means a
need to share. And what we're seeing in
all of these cases is that you can
increase the power of your sharing by
organizing your system and that's what is
going on here. So, thank you, and Carol
thanks you as well.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪